good morning Hank it's Tuesday wait it's
Tuesday that means that I am no longer
for the United States I am now all in
for Mexico hey cuz you know I'm
auctioning off my World Cup support for
sarcoma Research link in the doobly-doo
every time you donate $1 I donate 3 and
in total we've now raised more than 55
thousand dollars to fight sarcoma which
is so awesome hey why are you only just
stick you lating with one hand well
funny story
so as you know I'm a retired
semi-professional FIFA player for years
I uploaded my FIFA videos to YouTube
people watch them advertising revenue
etc but a while ago I decided to retire
from professional FIFA playing because
I'm older now in the physical and
emotional strain had just gotten to be
too much I decided I had to play just
for the love of the game for the love of
the pixels so all the money we make now
goes to an actual football club AFC
Wimbledon owned by its fans the first
football club to come out against
homophobia in England they're just
amazing
right ok so if you're like me and you're
not actually very good at FIFA it's not
enough to like press the joystick in the
right directions and hit the right
buttons you have to create a loving
supportive environment for your team
made of pixels so that they feel
comfortable scoring now for me a big
part of that is yelling at the screen
sometimes like pulling this way when I
want them to go that way but it also
involves some singing and then when they
score I want to celebrate with them all
of this is to say Hank that recently the
AFC wimbledon wimbly won we scored a
goal so beautiful so amazing that I did
what any manager would do I shot up my
arms and I shouted FC wimbledon only i
did it with both arms because that was
back when I could move both of my
shoulders that's right Hank I shot my
right arm into the air after scoring a
goal in a video game and seriously
injured my shoulder how seriously not
yet clear waiting for some test results
how do you injure yourself playing a
video game actually no I did not injure
myself playing a video game I injured
myself celebrating my success playing a
video game
so yeah Hank this whole experience has
made me realize something I'm old I have
a lot of gray hair over here but in the
two months of promoting The Fault in Our
Stars movie I got a lot of new gray hair
up in here now I thankfully you're not
old and as far as I can tell you never
will be you have the body of a man in
his 30s but the personality and face of
an excited 9 year old which I mean as a
comp
so Hank hopefully you'll be the brother
who doesn't get old and like stays hip
and cool but nerdfighters I am getting
old
in fact I'm older than I was when I
started this video I'm having a little
bit of a crisis about being old because
I want to be a nerdfighter for the rest
of my life so I'm hoping there are other
old nerdfighters I think there are but
mostly I just wanted to say I hope we
can still be friends even though I am
old and shoulderless again we get the
doobly-doo to our World Cup fundraiser
you can follow along the World Cup with
me at my sports Twitter sports with John
Hank don't play video games too
strenuously I will see you on Friday